one two three you got I can't tell you
the last time I try to be like I was
something I tried in my youth and I was
like this is not for me I think the last
time I had a peek was probably the first
time I had one there's different flavors
I'm not a peep lover or a fighter just I
want to see where I stand mmm I'll try
anything once these are smaller than
remember or thought they would be it's
really shiny like only it's glittery
it's very glittery well people go it up
okay let's just start with the fact that
like they are shaped like birds I think
I might go the peak but I'm gonna be me
yes eat the booty keep actually we just
I'm just gonna have that James oh my god
I'm scared I'm scared
I like this Wow I don't hate this just
like I remembered them it's really Airy
mm-hmm but not as chewy as I thought it
was gonna be
it tastes like if you just like took a
spoon and put it in like this bag of
sugar and like ate it I'll eat this
higher Pete
[Music]
coconut Jenny gets coconut first off the
yahh here this is like an almond joy oh
this is better than the last one I'm
gonna say that I don't hate it
but I think what I'm liking is it
chocolate wow that should not take that
much effort to chew it's a little tough
what that helped you know what I mean
this is a creamsicle oh my god right I'm
afraid it's gonna taste like medicine
like motrin yeah I would love to
Instagram these like it's festive I'm
like him are you kidding you know I
actually like this one
the texture is good I still would put
that above even the first beam I think
this makes me a Pete believer I would
eat one of these first of all the idea
of taking cotton candy and putting in a
team that looks like this same thing is
it cotton candy sure is this is crazy if
you love sugar you're gonna love sugar
sugar I mean if you're gonna eat this
much sugar and not eat cotton candy it
might as well taste like cotton candy
yeah it tastes normal there just tastes
like a marshmallow it's nice to look at
it's pretty pretty pink its Millenial
pink is that a color yeah like what I've
been there : right now out of it
strawberry burn watermelon our
watermelon strawberry it's hard to tell
I was expecting like cinnamon oh I would
listen and maybe would have been nice
but it's it's not it's definitely not
okay good good Oh what this smells like
really good it has like a slight
sourness to it so I don't mind it I
really don't well it actually tastes
like kool-aid I can't beat that fruit
punch okay a Gazette I get it too I
totally get it
I love fruit punch coming into this I
thought I was a peat purist but now I
don't know I don't know who I am anymore
I'm gonna go stare in the mirror for an
hour I've eaten more peeps today than I
have in my entire life same the best was
fruit punch I actually liked the
original peep the best could just he's
like a sugary marshmallow that fruit
punch want us I think we're in agreement
the best was by far the fruit yeah it
was really good I do kind of like peeps
I know I didn't let's stop the pee page
push it up it anyone out there
we're part of the problem I think I need
a dream yeah me too
I have tequila I'm gonna swing my
Starfighter done
[Music]